Hello and welcome to this next video where we will be looking at the interface and
looking at some basic controls.
Now in the previous video we've created a project, I've just jumped into it here.
You should be confronted with a screen that looks a little bit like this.
If you've previously used it, you might get a slightly different layout,
but all the elements are going to effectively be there.
So let's go through the sections piece by piece.
The first thing we have up the top here is our menu bar.
For this menu bar functions like most other menu bars and applications.
There will be different menus that will open up and allow you control over the project.
One thing that is worth noting is windows.
The reason windows is specifically interesting is because if you are missing any of the other windows that we talk about,
you'll find that you can switch them on or off here.
For example, if you were missing a details panel, you could come in here, tick on,
and this would open up a new details panel for you.
So this is just interesting because if I reference some kind of menu and you can't find it,
it will usually be because it's not turned on here.
The second part is across the top here. This is our tool bar.
Now this is going to have a number of different selections.
The first one is save. This will save the current level.
It will save the layout of the level you have in front of you to disk.
It won't have anything else, so they'll just save the current level,
but it will mean anything that you've moved around will be saved.
It will also have browse.
Now this is all over the engine as we use it.
It allows us to browse within a content browser.
Now if you click on it, you'll see there brings up content browser,
and it automatically highlights, in this case, the level.
So that's a good example.
We'll talk about the content browser as we'll learn later on.
Next up, all we have is the mode.
We are at the moment in selection mode,
and we will look at a couple of the other modes as we're going on.
Next we have add, quickly add to the project.
And what this is going to do is this is going to give us some options
to either import, get content.
It allows to brooring content in from other places,
such as the fab store or Cooksville bridge,
or just manually import from files.
It will also allow us to place different actors within the level.
An actor is a reference to anything which is in the level.
For example, if I was to come up here and select a shape, sphere,
you can see that it adds this sphere to all of them.
Next to that, we also have a couple of other options.
We're not going to touch on these in a moment,
but here we have the play button.
If I was to press play,
you would see that our character is generalized into the world.
We are able to run the application or gain inside the editor.
We'll touch on that a bit more later as well.
In the center we have the viewport,
and this is the visual representation of the level or world that we're working on.
We'll go over this in detail in a minute.
On the right-hand side, we have the outliner.
Now, what the outliner is, is a list of all of the different
actors. We reference actors, but actors means anything that is inside the level.
As you'll see down here, some of them have a visual element to them,
some of them just exist in space.
If I was to come in here and select, say for example, a cylinder,
and if I was to press P.
You would see that this cylinder has a representation in the world,
and it is also as a part of the list in the outliner.
This is very useful for us to be able to find and select things accordingly.
Finally, down in the bottom here, we have a details panel.
Now, what the details panel is, is a contextual menu.
So, say for example, I select something within the scene or the outliner.
It will bring up all of the details for that selected object.
Now, this again, the details panel is something which we are going to see
all over the engine, all of the different menus.
It's always pretty much contextual.
So, whatever you have selected at any one point, it will have,
it will give you the options that are connected to that.
Now, let's have a bit of a deeper dive into our viewport.
Now, for the viewport, first thing you'll want to know is how to move around.
And I believe these are the most common ways of moving around.
If you are to hold down the right-hand mouse button, then use the W, S, A and D.
W moves forward, S backwards, A and D would strafe left or right.
That will allow you to move in the works.
And those will be in reference to the camera viewport.
Holding down the right-hand mouse button is going to mean that you can control the viewport.
I'll demonstrate that in a second.
We also have two more keys that allow you to go up and down.
And that is Q and E, again, with the right-hand mouse button down.
But the F key will allow you to focus on a selected actor.
You can see I tried that out a little bit earlier.
It allows you to jump and just focus on a single actor.
Finally, we have Alt and Left Click.
And this will allow you to orbit a selected actor.
Let's jump into the engine and try those.
So again, in this case, what I've done is I've held down the right-hand mouse button.
Now you'll see as I move the mouse, I can move the angle of the camera,
which is being used in the viewport.
And if I push W, I'll go forward, S backwards, A left, D right.
This will allow you to navigate and move around.
If you're used to playing computer games, this will feel quite natural for you.
Next up, we have from holding down the right-hand mouse button.
If I push Q, it will send me down.
Here, that's to increase or lower the altitude of the cone.
Finally, F.
Though if I was to select, say, this cylinder inside the level,
whereas if I was to press F, it would frame focus on that cylinder.
If I was to select something else, press F, it would move me directly.
The sphere that we brought in is a really useful way to very quickly get to an object.
We also do the same thing by selecting something inside the outline, pressing F to focus.
Now if we come back and focus on our sphere,
I hold down in this time the left-hand's button and hold.
Then as I move the mouse, I'm going to orbit that specific actor.
It's going to allow me to get the correct angle I want to get from it.
Another button that's worth knowing about is the mouse wheel.
It's going to allow you to zoom in and zoom out.
Now when you're working on levels, levels can get quite big.
And you might want to move between common places multiple times.
You don't want to have to spend your whole time running around trying to find a specific angle.
So for this, we have a bookmarking system.
And how a bookmarking system works is if you find a specific location,
say for example, I'm viewing here, I hold down control and one.
And then I also want one that views from above.
Move up here and press control and two.
Now if I push one, I will jump to the bookmark location and two, I will jump back to the other one.
So this is a really useful way to be able to jump between different points in the engine.
So again, to reiterate that in the bookmarking system,
if you just hold down the control and number key from zero to nine,
you can bookmark a location and you can then push zero to nine in order to jump to that location.
Because very useful as your levels get larger.
Next up, let's have a look at the options that we have across the top here.
So to start with, we have this element here, which is the camera speed.
This will allow you to speed up and slow down the camera as you move around the world.
It is also connected to the middle mouse button.
So if you hold down the right mouse button, you can scroll in order to speed up and slow down the cap.
And this again is really useful if you want to get a very specific angle.
You can get close by going fast.
And then you can reduce the speed so that you can get absolutely perfect.
So this is the speed of the camera.
We also have a couple of other options here under this dropdown.
So it's going to allow us stuff like, for example, we can change the field of view, the near plane,
and some of the camera options going to game view.
And right at the bottom here, we're able to take a screenshot.
You'll also see that we have some orthographic options.
For example, we can come into top view.
Then we get something that looks like this.
Now you'll notice when we move into top view or orthographic,
we are locked into one axis.
Well, you'll also notice that this has gone wire-free.
Now it brings me to the menu that's right of this.
This gives us a number of different view mode settings.
By default, we would be on lit.
That's going to give us the bioframe from above like this.
However, we also have pun-lit, which is just going to give us the albedo or the base color pass.
Wireframe is very useful so that we can tell where objects are.
We have the lit wireframe as well, which will give us a combination of the wireframe and the models beneath it.
And there are lots of other ones to look through, far too much for us to go over in this instance.
You could also select bottom left, right, right, front.
I'm going to go back to perspective.
And that brings us to a logical point to stop or the interface.
We've looked at the different windows that were connected up and we've learned how to move about.
In the next video, we're going to look about bringing assets into the editor.
Thank you for watching.